there's no idea at the back of my head I
think I'd always been interested in
filmmaking but I kind of cut through
that dream away because it's quite hard
to get into the film industry in the
year but then I go here make youtube
channel and actually before I got to
Japan
it wasn't many huge TVs in Japan I was
like I'm really excited what's Japan
like they were on YouTube and there
wasn't a whole lot going on no offense
to the TVs in Japan free then free 2012
but it wasn't much that okay maybe I can
fill that void and take my hobby of
filmmaking and my dream that I've
forgotten and actually can I use that
and do something with it
so I hadn't watched the whole lot
achieve up until that point right I kind
of draw a lot my influences from British
TV and are the rather than other kind of
vloggers and other youtubers yeah yes
because like I think anyone can agree
they're like you watch any one of your
videos and it deftly has more of like a
TV vibe than like a traditional like hey
guys yeah it doesn't feel like an
inspiration on YouTube which a lot of
channels that have come into it newer do
feel like they're trying to emulate a
style built on it whereas I feel like
maybe that is what is certainly unique
about your your take on a vlogging I
mean yeah blogging the thing that
excited me was met the idea of making
like a crappy low-budget TV show rather
lock about Japan yeah seems like guiding
star it's it get gave off the impression
of like a BBC not not BBC show but like
a short you'd seen like on on a show or
like a news broadcast about Japan or
about a different culture yeah that's I
think I think that's what like how I
found your content at first and you
mentioned being one of the first people
to do vlogs about or not vlogs but like
videos about you I'm all of evolve like
Laura DeVos do you remember the scene
back then of what vlogs were like it was
like a shaky cattle yeah 2012 right oh
Jesus
I mean yeah yes Russia and that's like
yes Russia was probably like the high
those are good times I feel like that
was the golden era of YouTube a sense oh
I feel like every era has its own thing
to it and I think it's easy to look back
and be like
that was the best time forget about all
those people filming that TV playing
calling how could we call that the
Golden Age stick a camcorder in a shoot
I think this was showering Japan the
only like vlogger really before this is
Michaela give me a break man Victor yeah
yeah like I've come to like know a lot
of the J blogs that leave here like
scene slate the J vlogging community is
so small in a sense that like once you
know a few you basically know everybody
enough eventually and like yeah I mean
you know meeting Chris and like meeting
a bunch of all the like smoke newer and
older yeah bloggers it's like it's
really interesting to see like just how
big it actually is because on the
surface I think if you if you don't know
a lot of them right does just seem like
Chris and a few other people yeah
whereas late there's just so many and
that's how you can kind of easily stay
in a bubble if you want to yeah how do
you feel about the current J walking
scene there I don't know really I don't
I'm friends with a lot of them but I
don't I don't watch that much I don't
cuz I live in Japan you know I don't
really wanna watch other other Japan
stuff I do my stuff I spent ages working
on a video in a room I upload it and
then I go off and drive around the
mountains and go yeah I've kind of felt
like to be disconnected from it a little
bit do you ever like see a video made by
the Jayhawk you like to do that like
sometimes just scrap it if that happens
or what's the common virus I was
thinking of doing a day-in-the-life
series and then youtuber called Paulo
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah a carbon copy
right yeah and that's fair enough he's
done it well if you didn't do it well I
think you did you better it's something
similar like with yourself well you did
like it yeah you can you did like a day
in the life of late abroad in Japan on a
bicycle no no lady
I think the thumbnails like you in a
Shinkansen oh yeah I did it once many
years ago maybe he got the inspiration
ha ha ha we never know
we did stay definitely